hello everyone we are back that viewers
choice and I'm Dennis Bora and those are
footsteps you're hearing they're coming
the other direction
not this one hello everybody the first
game is going to be played between two
people the pious Patriot and the Beast
let's see if they have something to tell
us no just check out this game we will
do so
so e4 e5 Knight f3 d6 this is heading
towards a Philidor type position Bishop
c4 some would just play d4 instead just
claiming that we have lots of pressure
against a pawn actually like two ways of
defending or pseudo defending the pawn
either defending with 97 Queeny 7 which
is funny looking but it's not bad or not
f6 which I played and I don't recommend
to anyone to do it ever because white
could take Knight takes and they'll just
keep chasing this Knight
that's never fun that's never fun so
there's nothing wrong with Bishop c4
Queenie 7 was played anyways d4 h6 now
you look at this position what would be
our first gut reaction who do we like
more
yeah black hasn't done much what's the
positives for whites perspective
the centerpieces Castle yeah
a lot of pieces out but there's one
thing that my messes up in this game
meaning he/she doesn't really understand
how you need to punish your opponent
when they're lagging in development now
d5 is a huge mistake here why is the 5
such a big mistake in this position d5
definitely closes the center in as you
pointed out you need to open up the
position so let's be better than pious
Patriots and try to find a better way
actually the five is not too good
like it's mostly
he takes e5 that's a good idea
how would you follow it up after Detex
though
castle and doubling on the D foul that's
reasonable
what else good might do here
it's one more idea that wasn't mentioned
yet
oh it's more like yeah it's more of a
positional idea it's not like you're
winning yet yeah Knight c3 that's a very
good move and what's your idea here
actually you also have the idea of
jumping to d5 temple on the Queen which
would be huge you're already like three
moves up but you would force black to
play c6 and now obviously you can
continue with the idea of castling and
trying to rush your opponent down the
board but the black playing c6 d5 is not
entirely stupid now because we are
threatening to take on c6 and then the
position opens up and if like that say
takes normally we like to take stuff
with development but then we can jump to
d5 and already this situation is like
quite pleasant for white so they would
have to resort to like moves like c5
which is just ugly now again I'm not
saying we're winning and we're usually
not winning when the position is closed
with these pawns like blocking the way
it's hard for white to win the game
immediately but in the long term white
is a lot of development so let's say V
Castle okay g6
we need to find a way here to break
through there could be potentially
breakthrough in this position with light
obviously we have lots of time it's a
closed position so you can maneuver your
pieces around before you execute the
opening move
actually these positions are tricky
because if we wait for too long then
black will have the time to castle
to be one yes Ruby 1v4 is a good idea
here let's say they ignore us and the
good thing is as the bishop moves away
this d6 pawn gets really weak so just
weed let's say six Bishop a3 and then we
will slowly slowly have ideas of
attacking that pawn let's say Knight f6
I'm just playing
vini not good move rook b6 and already
this d6 pawn is dropping Ruby one was
really good and this is a typical idea
in these close positions to open up this
black center would be for the other
technique that we use is 91 wonder where
this knife and I just had it yes like
Bishop g7 97 f4 now usually black takes
the pawn because if white gets the
chance to push it to that 5 it's just
going to be a one-sided game so black
would take I should we take back bishop
yes because if you take with the knight
then this night is really not doing
anything
in fact after 95 this night on the e5 is
way better than this one laughs 4 and
that's because it has an outpost that's
usually created when you have a pawn
that supports your night and it anchors
it now that's why Bishop takes f4 Knight
f6 and in fact we have this really nice
little tactical idea of e5 which is very
typical in many many closed openings
this a 5 strike especially that the
black king is not castled and that's why
we Castle quickly I would advise
everybody to castle quickly because here
it takes you can even sacrifice here
takes bishop takes e5
it's a free piece it seems but but now
we have this nasty little thin rookie
one and yeah you can move the king but
then you drop your queen there's only
one way to defend it right now and that
is to blockade this idea that's 94 but
then we can just capture with the rook
because it can be captured this Knight
takes e4 okay we had a little bit of a
detour but this is how you supposed to
play closed positions with white if your
opponent is closing the position you're
supposed to open it somehow so in this
position we figured you have to maneuver
this night all the way to d3 to open up
the position so he played d5 as we
already said this is not a good idea
because we're supposed to open the
position the first place
now black or opponent is not in any
trouble anymore Knight f6 92 92 not
happy with Knight d2 I still liked and I
don't see 3 instead because the knight
on D 2 is very passive it only defends
this pawn ok defense this bishop as well
but it doesn't do anything apart from
that it's an ID - Bishop g4 b3 ok a
little bit strange but it's ok 9 8 7
again bit strange how could we develop
bit black in this position 9 8 7 is an
OK move but you should play something
else I think
what other ideas we could have here with
black notice our king is not in any
safety on the 8th so what should we do
them if our King is unsafe actually just
raise your hand if you and an idea I'll
call on you yeah yeah yeah yeah the
queen is a bit really place but it's not
like a big issue as I said the position
is so close that so g6 is an idea
all right let's say g6 here here and
what should we play with both colors now
because if we think about it both Kings
are kind of unsafe their castle castle
that's all castles and now it's going to
be a long game but we know that our King
is in safety which is very important all
right so this is ignored by both played
five eight seven Bishop b2 Knight g5
which is nice because he is trying to
enforce the spin but this night only to
defend everything so even though this
night on d2 is passive it defends these
crucial pawns and Knights so kh3
obviously wants to get rid of that
Bishop peeny to a6 g4 this is okay
shove g6 long castle now
you can short castle anymore because
then you would lose the pawn on h3 and
Knight f4 and this is lost
so why already has no choice but to
castle long but castling long always
entails danger mostly because it's much
easier to attack a king
it's on the queenside 97 h4 that
accessory takes night c5 so what's the
biggest concern in this position that
white right now what does our opponent
want to do right now keep yeah just
brought so this Bishop was already
attacking the e4 pawn how many pieces we
need to actually win this pawn so
there's one defender here defending the
pawn one attacking is that enough is
that enough to capture that pawn not
really we need to bring another attacker
just to overload on e4 now we have two
defensive methods in this position which
one should we choose I mean this eve or
pawn is hanging the screen cannot defend
it by itself
mmm-hmm Bishop d3 that's an idea how
else could a part from Bishop d3 how
else could be defended for pawn
yeah so there's 92 and Bishop d3 now
white played h5 missing that the pawn
was just hanging but that's not good now
what's wrong with Bishop d3 in general
I'm not I don't as I as you can tell I'm
not happy with the bishop moved to d3
what's something that's kind of bad
about this move
well the thing is I can take this Bishop
anytime I want
and you can never move it because let's
say I play Queen d7 I can't move it
because you just take the pawn if I move
this one now again I can take it and so
instead 92 is just better because your
opponent just can't take your Bishop yet
at least now he can force you to move
the bishop and do this but at least
there's this level of concession here by
black I'm not saying it's terrible but
it's something
okay so h5 Bishop takes e4 b4 so what is
trying to open up stuff and initiate
some action just in the wrong way
because Black has this move Bishop takes
f3 otherwise it would work because if
you have to move the knight I can take
your bishop but obviously I can take
this take and my day for and especially
in closed positions try to have Knights
because these these bishops just are
useless in this position they don't do
anything
so Queen b3 b5 rookie one night b2 again
missing a tactical idea having the
concept almost right he does want to
open up the position but there were like
threats like this pawn is heavily
threatening taking on c4 so Bishop d3
was a must so rook e1 Knight B to takes
the rest is basically agony like it's
just up a piece and c5 is a little
sketchy it's a bit too much like didn't
need to give away an extra pawn here
good I've just gone King g7 and when but
okay this position is just so winning
for black that any kind of Miss
eggs is enough so it was kind of an easy
win so I wanted to show game to where
both players handled close position much
better than the first one it's not
flawless but they handled it the way
better
so b3 Larsen strikes again c5 c6 d3
knight c6 Knight d2 so it's kind of like
a reverse nimzo-indian
if you're familiar with that it's
basically this opening d4 just like c4
c6 this and let's say Castle take the
reversed colors is the same system same
concepts that's what white is aiming for
in this game
III although without the bishop moving
out Knight f3 Knight f6 Bishop e2 now
Bishop e2 is a bit conservative actually
there's a better way of developing your
pieces if you play this kind of position
how could we improve on our bishop
instead of putting it on e2
there's actually two ways to achieve
that
mm-hmm yeah so as you said d4 would be a
little weird cuz you already played
these three and you're wasting time
but then you can actually move your
Bishop to d3 which is much better than
e2 so this is like a give-and-take and
chess sometimes you sacrifice time just
to make a better move actually g3 is the
same concept you sacrifice time for a
better piece saying that okay okay you
got an extra move but I got an extra
extra good bishop on g2 we have two
monsters just slashing down the board
and when you play Bishop e2 you're kind
of saying oh one is enough
but in chess just take any benefits and
advantages you can get because you might
not get it back ever
b5 which is a decent move but sometimes
in chess you can try to play against
your opponent white only has one really
good piece and that's the bishop on b2
so I can black possibly play against
that
think about walling in this bishop if it
hits the brick wall it can be useless
yes well if you play e5 I can take you
because I attack you twice yeah d6 and
then e5 and this was actually one of
those spectacular concepts that Fischer
used against Larsen actually patrician
sorry but the Larsen system patrician
didn't go with this night that three
beasts beast b3 ideas but then Bishop
lady 65 and that Bishop was out of the
game forever this is actually even
better because of these two pawns
because white would try to play d4 but
here I can take take efore and just
build a center and still your Bishop on
b2 is just horrible
so d6 would have been a really good idea
here
so he played d5 which gave breathing
space for this Bishop which is not a
good idea if your black castles Bishop
d7 95 there's an Indian way of playing
but again already why I could have tried
c4 takes you would obviously take
towards the center and we would be
planning d4 ideas and it's a game but I
like white because white has this really
nice bishop on b2 while black really
doesn't have this extra good piece play
95 Knight takes takes Queen e7 we need 7
is so passive even in the previous game
we saw it's too passive so how else
could black develop here
yeah Bishop e7 and castles and that's
fairly normal the other thing that you
could do is Bishop c6 it the same
concept that I kind of laid out before
meaning I could put this Bishop on e7
but I would be happiest to put this
Bishop on d6 and be more active and
sometimes it's worth wasting a move just
to make a better move later on so Queen
e7 is worse than me waiting with a move
you're actually make your position even
more miserable h3 which is kind of
strange because you don't need this move
long castle now this is pure suicide but
again in closed position slight mistakes
can be forgiven in fact black can still
make a very decent move here and still
put the black King into safety so if you
have an idea raise your hand and I'll
call on you so yes you already that
block the way for this bishop to go this
way it doesn't mean we can go the other
way around yeah yes g6 and even though
we're wasting a lot of time and we kind
of scared that maybe our opponent will
place c4 managed to take and already we
can see the downside of wasting time we
can take with the knight anymore
because we just lose the bishop so we
have to take with the pawn you'll play
d4 we get an isolated pawn but at least
we could put our King into safety and
okay this is not anyone's dream with
black but it's still a fight long Castle
is like okay the long castle idea is
like okay just shoot here so this is not
good
so why decides to attack immediately
correctly now is there a reason to panic
with black not yet there's only this
Bishop glaring down our King which is
kind of concerning but it's not the end
of the world we have lots of pieces
around so in closed positions we might
have the time to look for counter play
but first we have to decide very well
Valar contour plate be inside Kings side
in the middle
probably not in the middle because that
would take us a lot of time to get our
pieces out there
so there is this idea of Bishop c6
that's what he played which is good
you bring the bishop closer as a
defender also your queen will defend
against Queen c7 mating ideas you might
actually think about d4 but that's kind
of you're not developed enough to open
up the center is white ready to open up
the center yes why it is because he
castled so should be ready he plays a3
which is fine as well but you could also
go d4 and open the position up here on
the other hand a3 is a sly idea because
white says okay I want to open up the
position on the Queen side and if you
take stuff there I'll be happy cuz I
want to attack just right there on the B
line and a line in fact you could have
tried b4 here immediately C takes and
then a3 kind of banker like ideas of
just sacking the pawns just to open up
the position does that say takes I
immediately have the B line to attack
you now this is double-edged though
because I'm down to pawns
which is not a good trade so that's why
I played a3 like decided to go g5 and I
like this because black realized okay
you're not mating me soon enough so I
can't try to care you on the other side
rook b1 and I think Ruby runs a bit slow
you already have b4 here because you
can't even take it all the way cuz this
and eyedrops and even though this is a
closed position time will matter in the
end you can't just wait around if your
opponent's drag strikes first
so Ruby 1 was played rook g8 it makes
more sense for black to prepare it
because there's not enough pieces
defending the g4 push right now
Oh g8b for h5 it's just kind of
interesting
b5 now in this position I would consider
both me 5 and B takes e5 what's the plus
and minus of taking the ball
mmm-hmm what's a minus though
the B file is open now but he did lose
something with taking on c5 right it's
not a flexible concept because we don't
have the idea of rolling with the pawns
anymore so when we took we kind of
decided okay we're going to make or just
develop an attack with the rook and if
we push the pawns we give the
opportunity of checkmating the other way
around so that's what he decided he
played b5 I'm sure he considered taking
which is not necessarily a bad move but
b5 seems more flexible he takes he takes
a four now a four is too slow this time
it's a it's following the concept of
okay I'm slowly building the attack and
I'll crash through eventually but what
if you don't so that's why sometimes you
still have to look for good and much
better solutions yes
yeah Queen a4 immediately was almost
crushing because you're just threatening
Queen a8 which is quite difficult to
handle b6 is just checklist so green a4
was winning and I think this is one of
the problems even like grandmasters and
super grandmasters fall into obviously
in higher levels that they become too
dogmatic they follow one plan that they
decided they're going to follow all the
way
so why decided already after a three
that okay I'm just gonna roll my pawns
and it's gonna work and they didn't
spend the time to say okay this is a new
situation I might have new opportunities
to finish it off and in that way you
would have found clean a4 immediately
obviously this is not such a hard thing
to find here but if you're kind of
blitzing and I can see this was a blitz
game
sometimes it's detrimental just to play
a move play one plan that you already
decided to choose so a for g4 and
actually it's turning into a race now
Bishop takes f6 and this is a bad move
Bishop f6 is not good and the reason is
this bishop was a really good attacker
and the defender potentially and you're
just giving it away for free
like nobody forced you to do that so how
could we parry or at least react to this
idea of g4 what does our opponent want
to achieve that's actually the first
thing that we look at yes yeah black
black really wants to take on h3 so
we're trying not to help our opponents
so what should we do that
just h4 obviously in this way let's say
Knight h7 and we really get scared we
can still go Bishop g3 and there's no
more attack for black and they're happy
so this is definitely what white should
have done takes on f6 Queen takes f6 and
notice that this awful Queen on e7 is
suddenly a monstrous Queen on f6 it's
not as good for white anymore and then
now comes this move h6 g4 which is the
worst idea ever because you're actually
helping your opponent to checkmate you
takes takes Queen eight six that's fine
let's play something else
like Bishop d6 seems really nice
and why decide where to put the Queen so
early it's possible that your queen will
belong to h4 or even e5 and now it gets
really scary let's say Bishop h3 Queen
h4 king h1 and I think you already
smelled it
something stinks here for white
there's like a crushing blow
yep yep I have to take
robe she hates wife who desperately love
to run away but
eh five just stops that poor King from
escaping cuz well some people might know
who plays the dragon that the White King
I mean the black King can actually
escape this way and because of this on
fortress your King is very safe there
but no such luck because Queen age five
and you lose that's checkmate so that's
how easy it is to lose an almost solely
winning game now he didn't do that
because black didn't play Bishop d6 but
that's why Bishop d6 would have been way
better because you don't need to decide
where to put the Queen just yet peen
eight six Queen f3 and it actually gave
time for white at five Bishop h3 now I
know this Bishop on h3 looks very stupid
but the biggest threat for from black
was is taking on g2 this is actually a
good defender now so the game turns
again Bishop d6 rook F c1 which is fine
because this is a very nice move its
preparing d4 and what does recap c1
prepare
the evacuation of the king before you
don't have space for the king you might
have to go this side which where you
don't want to go and then facts after
fc1 you can go f1 and do the same thing
that I showed you just evacuate the king
into safety rook g5e for this is not the
good idea you're kind of helping your
opponent you should be playing D four or
a five something just try the checkmate
on the other side or run but don't open
up the position for the black bishops
before you g8e five is reasonable but
it's still not that good should be seven
D for group g6 which is a bit mysterious
probably is planning to triple but it
just does nothing a five we could have
taken the pawn obviously but a five
there's nothing wrong with a five green
g7 but again the problem is that the
bishop on h3 those rooks do nothing
that's not a threat of taking and
especially after rook F c1 I can just
walk away if you take on g2 b6 takes c4
which you can is strange King b8 takes
and sadly there's not enough material
for black to do anything you ship c6
Knight takes e4 which is a cute tactic
because D takes c4 runs into mean six
takes 93 Roxy 757 it's just agony now
and just checkmates so I think what we
learned is not to make a quick decision
just develop your pieces and dance see
where your attack is going because I
think that's what black messed up a
little bit is just trying too hard to
bring an attack with that fene eight-six
move when the Queen was really doing
well on f6 and also white shouldn't have
opened up the position in front of his
game that was kind of helping black and
that's not a good idea
all right so I want to show two more
games so this game played between bukit
lawang and thing is beyond in this game
I'm trying to gain an advantage using
the London system but it is only towards
the end that I'm winning thanks to some
fungus by my opponent how can I better
utilize the system to get a winning
position earlier on in the game cheers
from the Norwegian fan of your club and
YouTube channel V chess let's rating
1350 so d4 d5 again I don't think the
London is winning so I wouldn't expect
London to win you outright you can be
better and you can outplay your opponent
there but there's no reason to believe
that that's such a great opening it's
decent
but main lines are main lines for a good
reason
c4 c6 and in fact you're not playing
you're playing the main line like this
is the main line this is not the London
the London is Bishop f4 now
you can try to play these London kind of
positions let's save it here here and
III
and c4 you can combine these two they're
not bad together in it in fact you can
transpose to this classical system
played between Karpov and Korchnoi
fortunately cop of especially this
classical game
oh not a5 between a5 a3 and rook e8 and
this was actually an idea played by the
Karpov team so yeah actually this was
knight c6 first rook the one and then
wookie 8 but anyways so you can play
these longer types of positions with c4
but usually what people do is go Knight
d2 c5 c3 castles Bishop d3 now if you
want to know more about this Eric Rosen
does a good job with it but I'd still
think it's better to play main lines
because then you get an advantage here
not really
so anyways c4 c6 Knight f3 e6 Bishop f4
and this is not a good way the way
you're playing this because this time I
can capture on c4 and if III then b5 and
you'll never get that pawn back the
other problem is as you might say that
oh okay III doesn't work but April a 4
would work well the problem is then
there is this nasty move of 95 double
attacking the bishop and the night you
might have to move away but then I I can
defend this c4 pawn in many ways I can
just go like for this kind of concepts
just holding on to it or try to play b5
at some moment let's say b5 takes I take
on c3 take
see Tech's and maybe you have some
compensation but usually practically you
really don't
so this is not a good thing so in
general if you want to play the London
you have to prepare and develop your
pieces first and then you can play C for
so you have to play Bishop back for 933
first and e3 so that the bishop will
protect the c4 pawn but here you can't
do this you should have been punished
for this way 97 C takes d5 and this is
again not too ambitious to take on d5 in
general in these Queens gambit
structures to taking on d5 even though
it's playable it's not too ambitious and
black plays C takes which is okay but
after it takes d5 for example white has
no advantage at all because you lost the
central control like has just as much
control as why does so it's around the
equal in fact you should play e3 here
and if here just Bishop d3 and castles
and you supposed to be slightly better
here so if you actually manage to
combine this Bishop f4 e threes and c4
you are expected to be better and I
would say that more confidently than in
the other case when you have the Bishop
f4 out but the pawn on c3 that's just
playable so you took on d5 he took with
the C pawn which I don't think is a good
idea
he takes is better C takes III a6 kind
of defending as the snide b5 ideas and
jumps but then the question comes up why
does not be 5 doesn't work in this
position so there are two reasons
yes
yeah Bishop b4 check and what's the
concept behind the Bishop b4 check yeah
so something does have to move back and
then in that way so if the bishop moves
back that night on b5 alone is not
threatening enough if you move other
pieces that's too awkward and especially
this is one fine trick I want to show
you guys it's night c7 is not too smart
because I have g5 ideas and this is a
trip typical trick because take stakes
even though black only wanna piece this
night on eight will never survive
because we'll just go b6 Bishop e7
quickly and even if white would try to
help this beautiful nights there the
night before would double attack on d2
and this is very painful and lost so
that's the reason I b5 doesn't work here
III now it will work a little bit more
so black plays a6 h3 a good classical
way of playing the London you're
providing some shelter for the bishop
because if you would play like Bishop d3
night h5 gains strengths if you move the
Bishop to g5 exchange you which is not
the concept of these London kind of
plays and if you go to g3 again I can
take on g3 so therefore your h3 move was
thematic and very good h3 and b6 this
type just looks dumb on b6 so that's not
a big fan of that so I would rather play
Bishop e7 this time Castle and then go
b6 Bishop e7 and just be solid because
this time the night on b6 just looks
dumb Bishop b4 and even if I play Knight
b6 I'd still play Bishop d6 instead at
least trying to exchange this [ __ ]
so this should be for castle castle
Brooksie one now you have a very good
position with white because this Bishop
on c8 is just bad 77 you see to mean b3
now that's too much hesitation you
should jump into e5 and prepare the idea
of Bishop g5 let's say we create then
Bishop g5 is getting really strong and
sometimes even this nasty check on h7 is
bad bad news for black because if the
King moves its mate you have to go to f8
and I want to be black so Knight e5 is
the way to play these type of positions
just preparing Bishop g5 and white
supposed to be better here Queen b3 is a
bit slow not bad but slow 87-95 now yeah
but you could have done it the other way
around
Knight c4 takes that was a free pawn now
if you're worse and you don't have much
space what should should be aim in these
type of positions with black if you
don't have space there's one good method
that people advise you to do yeah trade
so we should trade on c3 and see how it
goes let's say takes takes Oh nuts
tonight c4 takes now B takes is stronger
but if we get lucky we can maybe
exchange the bishops and already the
situation kind of got slightly better
I'm sure that black is worse because
maybe even Queen if I win something but
at least you can fight here when you
play Knight c4 you still are saddened
and have this bad bishop on d7 which is
not good so Bishop takes c4 Brook c6
page 2
and as you can see black did get some
activity but it's a free pawn so it's
not enough
Queen f8 a3 good if you're up up
material exchanges are good for you so
if you're up upon feel happy to feel
free to exchange stuff the only thing to
be concerned of is don't exchange
everything because then you'll drop
takes rook takes c3 this is very good
play so far takes d4 f3
very good although loosening the Kings
position and you don't want to do that
you're just giving away targets so I
would prefer rook e1 you have a safe
King because sometimes you get unlucky
and fall into some tactical tricks
because you made your Kings position
shaky f3 look at the eight there should
be 5
I don't like that move I'd prefer
something like Queen C 3 because Bishop
e5 is again a little bit exposing your
pieces 97 a very good move asking so
where is that Bishop going Bishop h2 not
a good move because repetition and now
Queen c3 okay that's a good one though
and that's a good thing that you have
the patience to build up your position
even if it frustrating that sometimes
you make like slight inaccuracies teeny
7 Bishop takes a6 very good because
black can take the pawn I mean this
Bishop end upon because I can take this
pawn and I'm just so many pawns up its
dead winning so Queen e7 takes Queen d7
the 5 takes takes
95o this gone bad quickly so you
shouldn't have played d5 in the first
place you could have just moved a bishop
back let's say to see four takes takes
to just defend the bishop and you're
just winning you have the extra pawn you
have the bishop there you don't have to
do anything interesting d5 is too
interesting in this position you're
giving away a pawn for no reason and
also you're not moving a piece that's
attacked and that's your Bishop g5 takes
now you're actually not better anymore
takes takes maybe three takes and you're
down a piece
you're supposed to be lost now it takes
you have some pawns but this is
objectively lost ooh
it should be five yes I thought I saw
hands no okay yeah this is not good now
takes and let me see what happened Oh
awesome white actually lost oh okay so
that's sad because you actually had but
white beautiful position and this is
very sad because you did everything
right you just didn't defend your pieces
and the biggest mistake was forgetting
of your own piece of safety like the
only thing you needed to do is to bring
the bishop back taketake rook c1 and
you're on the track of winning this game
d5 to me seemed a bit panicky like oh my
god what's going to happen but what I
learned that you don't really need to
panic just defend your pieces that's it
and here black only had one threat of
taking your bishop obviously you lose
the pawn well what can you do the bishop
is worth more than the pawn to Bishop c4
is something I do instead and I'd assume
that you would win otherwise this was a
really good game by you
I think that white played well here the
only thing that I really didn't like was
playing loosely a little bit like f3 I
don't think you need it to do that
rookie one was better and then just
continue from here try defending your
pieces and if you start defending your
pieces you win way more games in general
because by now blacks position is so bad
that the only way they can beat you here
if you blunder something and
unfortunately for you blunders something
and that was the bishop but apart from
that a good game so this is all for the
viewers choice that I wanted to show
these games and we actually looked at
these semi closed closed positions how
you should and you how you shouldn't
play now as we learned you should not
close the position if you have more
pieces in the center try to open up the
position on the other hand if you're on
the other side try to close the position
as quickly as possible also in the last
game we learned protect your pieces even
if you're winning it's never too late to
blunder unfortunately all right that was
viewers choice and thank you for being
here
you
[Music]